when I read about your history with your
own father your father what what I
didn't know this was an alcoholic and he
would take you to AAA meetings that's
right we were going on a summer trip and
we were driving to Canada and my older
sister told me that as we were leaving
the drive apparently my father was
shit-faced so the poor man was possessed
by that demon but when he got into a he
was all in and and he he ran the show
and it was fantastic and I and I got to
go to one of those meetings and see him
in action and it was you know like open
mic night it was great
so he was a performer in other words the
the AAA meeting would give them an
audience that's correct yes that and
that's all he ever really wanted but he
had to make a living and in those days
what did you do it the guy could play a
pipe organ one of those giant
cathedral-like organs and go nuts on it
my grandmother I think wrote a letter to
a radio station in Louisville and saying
that she knew a guy who can do the organ
and if that had happened he would have
been a much happier different kind of
guy and and maybe that would have
intervened in the alcohol addiction so
he never realized the dream of using
that like he didn't get a show business
kind of always it no he did he tried
everything everything he did with the
church activities or associations with
his flower shop he liked to get up and
do jokes and he was a showman and he and
he wanted to do it and this was
heartbreaking at the old days when you
would get a Sunday paper and then they
would had the funny papers and they
would have the magazines in the Parade
magazine there was always an ad for the
American writer school do you think you
can write if you can write it so he
would clip out this thing and you send
them a deal and they will send you a
test to see if you can write and then
you would fill out the writing test and
they would send it back and then they
guess what yes you can write so I mean
even even then that made me sad because
I
that filling out a form in the Sunday
magazine was was not gonna get you on
the bestseller list I felt bad for him
because I don't think most men lead
lives of quiet desperation did you see
yourself as a nuisance to him as
somebody who holds him back like when
you were growing up with your like chief
my father said because he's got to make
a living for us and I'm holding him back
no I I think that the kids typically are
pretty selfish and it was until he
started having heart attacks that I
really felt really true strong empathy
for his plight and I remember a TV show
in Indianapolis and I hadn't be on the
show as a guest and I thought wow this
is the I I think that was good for both
of us
because I was able to give him that
opportunity give him that experience I
mean it was just a local morning TV talk
show but there I was talking to my
father and I yeah I don't know I thought
that was important
you